[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah this bread Levine right there and
that's a aka better off barefoot and
that's the name of that of the musician
Brad Levine could be Jewish could be
Hebrew maybe is I don't know if Israeli
is the terminal Avene one of my best
friends
Lavie is Jewish and I know that it could
be a similar name could be one of my
brews you get your bros you got your
brews that is Brad Levine aka better off
barefoot let's taking one more little
little kick of it he'll kick you in the
kicking me in the camel right
there boy
[Music]
little funk this morning Thank You Brad
Levine better off barefoot for
submitting that and helping us all get
on board on this Monday morning and I
had a little bit of funk you know I had
a lit of funk in my life this week and I
was in Jacksonville I was in
Jacksonville Florida and if you haven't
been to Jacksonville it's like the
Bermuda Triangle of it's basically like
a raw it's kind of like a Ross Dress for
Less but it's alive if you could imagine
that everybody seems a little it's like
everybody's it it seemed like first of
all it seemed like the whole place is
the witness protection program you were
in and people are gonna think that I'm
riffing on Jacksonville I actually had a
great time I had a great time but
Jacksonville I mean it's a it's a it's a
Bermuda Triangle if you lost a friend in
Jacksonville nobody would be like oh
that's crazy like yeah yeah you probably
did you probably misplaced a couple
family members over there in Jay Ville
Duval
that's what they say when you're there
they say Duval County and if you listen
to Jacksonville Jaguars games you can
hear that in the background Duval they
say that in that's Duval County because
that's a wild County and and because
Jacksonville I mean it's just everybody
seem like you're in the witness
protection program and I was even
talking about this on stage a sight
nobody's shaking nobody's giving out any
information everybody's kind of got a
court case pending a little bit and it's
diverse as can be you meet a white
person but they are black you meet a
black person but they are not they are
Jamaican you meet a Jamaican person but
they are Hispanic it says you don't know
what's going on you I mean you almost
need an attorney even just to introduce
yourself I mean you need like a not an
attorney like a word attorney a
translator you only see the translator
just to just to meet people because I
don't know I did not know what was going
on but we did it down there in
Jacksonville
and it's basically it's like it's kind
of like the Sacramento of Florida
because Florida is a wild place first of
all you have like um you know you have a
lot of money down at the bottom of
Florida along the coasts you know you
got a lot of good old boys and and and a
lot of black community are
african-american you and you also have a
lot of african-american I mean you have
like American black and you also have
African American like people that are
straight up from Africa you also have a
lot of you know Jamaica man you got that
I mean it's just a damn buffet and
that's what you get over there
and we were in Jacksonville and I was
performing at the comedy club and at
first I walked in man and I you know I
had some pretty you know not I don't
have any prejudices I had just against
the place it was like a huge comedy club
this comedy club it was like day it was
almost like in a gymnasium but they had
made a comedy club in there so it's huge
you know you could I mean your friend
could go to the bathroom never come back
you never see a friend again you never
hear from them maybe like a couple years
later you get invited to their wedding
like that kind of like I mean the
comedy club was probably 30,000 square
feet so you kind of like I remember when
I walked in I was like what the son
this has it's wild and my boy Dean down
there runs it and Dean used to play
football down there and now he runs his
business and he man we had a blast you
know and it just had it also had like
this kind of black business vibe and you
if you want to say that I mean that in a
racist way then you can say that but I
grew up in an environment where you had
black businesses and a black business
man they got everything anything could
happen in a black business you know you
walk the show you know the show supposed
to start at 10:30 it's gonna start at
11:00 that we're gonna have a fashion
show right before you don't sound like
just a surprise we having a
chili cook-off you're like it's 1:15 in
the morning and then they got a couple
of bad up there with bathtub
full of beans and meat and it's just
that kind of vibe and you don't you just
don't know what's gonna happen sometimes
like they could raffle off a Buick in
the middle of the show and you wouldn't
even be shocked so it just kind of has
that wild vibe you know but it was
awesome to see minute and then but at
first you know I was just I guess I was
humbled a little because I get used to
be in and maybe like sometimes fancier
clubs and you know you don't realize
that you you don't realize that you need
to be humbled until you are humbled you
know and I'm so grateful that kind of
stuff because the last thing I want to
get infected by is my ego because that
my ego will be the death of me and it
will be the death of my joy but man we
were in there and dude this guy so the
emcee is this guy Antoine and I don't
know if I've ever been around a guy that
was more entertaining to be around so he
you know he's a black gentleman and he
starts telling me that his favorite
television watching nine oh two one oh
reruns and man for some reason that just
I mean it just I don't know it's the
last thing I ever thought to hear hit
this dude say and we had um we just had
a mixed group in it was like three black
comedians three white comedians and
everybody was having a blast everybody
was having a blast man and you know we
were sitting backstage and people were
everybody was joking nobody was a better
jokester nobody was you know because
somebody was had only been doing comedy
for 10 months they weren't allowed to
joke or they weren't didn't feel like
they could put their two cents in
everybody in the greenroom all of us had
the worst haircuts I mean they had this
one dude one of the openers he looked
like every character from Roseanne all
in one person this Russian fella named
Andre and we have it
man I'm still having fun that's how much
fun I had this other guy
I can't what was his name I feel so bad
right now but all he kept asking me he
wanted to he had to have these new sex
robots at our out and it's like a $1,700
investment these sex robots and now they
got some of the urban ones you know but
I'm one of the ones that like a lot of
rappers and that sort of you know that
vibe that are going around in that vibe
you know the big ass is like all of a
sudden these robots are out here you
know they got big titties and you know
in these you know bought two Tot tots
boy these these butt tots you
know and they got these battery-operated
Cooter's and everything and they got
these ass cheeks and you can make them
pop and you know sprout or whatever they
call it I don't know what they call
whenever you shake your ass and somebody
you know just oh I think it's called
sprouting but they can all the robots
can do all this now so this dude
man that's how they hit this other
comedian guy and I don't remember his
name and he he wanted me to put a down
payment right on the heat because he
thought I had some money he wanted me
put a down payment on one of these
robots for him and man to listen to him
pitch this idea to me that you know if
you're gonna buy a robot you gotta
have a brother try it out first and it's
kind of up not to share you know
you know you don't want to be racially
insensitive and not share your
robot with a black man and I mean til we
were laughing so hard so I don't know if
you know what it made me feel good it
made me feel good to be in an
environment because there's so much out
there these days where you know there's
so much black and white that that's the
race problem in America you know because
when you really when you look at those
other other races seem to get along okay
you know where we seem to kind of evolve
in to each other some or try to I feel
like if you're not trying to do that
it might not be happening in your life
because it might not even be your fault
but if you're not trying you know then
that's that's probably not super solid
but I feel like it you know but black
and white seems to be that big issue
black and white and so it was just it
was nice to not be on the computer or
not be on social media or on Twitter
which is turned into a of just a bunch
of people just trying to farts I
mean it is just a fart on there and
I'm sorry to use that kind of language
and I really am you know but it is I
mean it there's a some people still
having a good time on Twitter and then
there's a bunch of furious people about
about politics and just a bunch of
Muppets out there
a bunch of button Muppets but it was
nice to be in a real environment with
regular people
talking about stuff and just having a
good time people who were not the same
as me you know and someone you might
think well Theo you talk a lot about
black and white stuff a lot and I guess
I do because that you know it's neat
it's pretty near to my heart I guess
because I see it as something that makes
a lot of uncomfort in our country and
and I think just in my own heart you
know you know because it's tough it was
it was tough growing up in an
environment where it was pretty mixed
and being a child you want to help
people you know or wanting to help
people that have less than you or it
feels like they have less than you or
you know and then get into adulthood and
being made to feel like you're not a
good person because you're white you
know when most your life you feel like
you've tried to make every effort not to
be white but to be a person so yes oh
man we had so much fun that it just it
melt by the end man I was having a blast
by the end I was doing comedy in a in a
warehouse dude you should have seen the
sign outside wasn't even lit up there
was a picture of it on my Instagram I'm
not a picture of it on the video do the
Sun like people they said two weeks ago
a homeless do rolled into the club he
roll dinner you know the children's
clothing or the automotive section or
whatever he came into this I think this
place is a warehouse and then they have
like a little stage against one wall and
then there's a ton of tables and you can
hear everything dude if somebody has a
bad idea
200 feet away from you you can hear it
go off in their head I mean the
acoustics were just not good but um but
we had a blast you know and we had so
much fun backstage that we couldn't help
but have fun on stage and when I go back
and do Florida again I have some of
those same guys come and work with me
again because I just had so much fun and
it was nice to be in an environment you
know when you hear all of this stuff oh
you know race relations are so bad and
people are you know and this and we
know equality and this and that and then
you get into a place where we all have
one common goal to make some people feel
some laughter and have fun and while one
dudes goal was to try to get you know me
to put 1700 hollers down on a robot he's
gonna in Florida you know it was
almost like that back to that Deebo
thing you know with like uh it'll be
both ours but I'll just keep it at my
house you know with Devo trying to steal
that boys bike and Friday but it was uh
man we had a blast we had a blast in
Jacksonville is I mean it's you want to
go to a place that's diverse and you
don't even know what's going on and look
man people have shitty shirts are
optional knew they had you see people
walking across the street maybe a shirt
maybe not I mean a dude will come
walking out of a restaurant no shirt
with a dog in his arms you know I'm not
talking about a guy that works for the
SP you know the pet rescue I'm talking
about just a regular dude a regular
playboy trying to get a snack you know
and man they were so excited about the
Jaguars about the Jacksonville Jaguars
playing that game and I think that team
played its heart out and I think that
they'll be in the AFC Championship for
the next couple of years they have a
really good chance but man we had so
much fun you know I had a good time and
I went in there a little bit you know I
guess cuz it reminded me sorry
Oh somebody just pledged on patreon and
I appreciate that I want to thank the
patreon supporters this week we got that
new camera coming in so we're gonna be
getting some new levels I can't thank
you enough really but I want it yes so
um but man we had we just had a good
time and we did it you know we got the
shows done and it was the audience's
were mixed and everybody was laughing
you know we were laughing man and it
just it was it was ridiculous but you
see a do man to have people in
wheelchairs people in high chairs people
on crutches people on stilts
Jacksonville you don't even know they
had one dude had a he said he got some
new bracelets he was in shackles
this dude was obviously it escaped from
prison he said he got these new
bracelets
I dunno buddies believe in that but
why don't you sit sit right up here by
the front of the stage so we can keep an
eye on you cat daddy but they had neck
tats Oh a lot of beautiful neck artwork
you know nothing to make you really
appreciate artwork like that like an
aorta running right behind it and and
the fans that came out you know I had a
special moment of this group had come
out a while back this man I think his
name was Nolan and his wife had come out
a while back and they were pregnant and
and then they came this time and he's
like do you notice anything different
and I remembered I remembered them but
he's like you notice anything different
and he's like kind of pointing at his
wife and I'm like you know in the
perverted me jumps to the front of my
head and I'm like you know you know I'm
thinking she got you know jumped up a
couple of cup sizes or something I don't
I don't know and I'm trying not to look
at his wife and we're right there and
then he showed me the picture you know
that the last time they were had they
had had a baby or were pregnant and then
this time they'd had a baby and just you
know it was just cool man they'd come
back out and like a special moment and
their life had gone on and it just made
I don't know it made me feel good to
like you know I was like a little bit of
part of their life and they were a
little bit of part of mine you know and
last
they'd seen me maybe I didn't have as
bad as a haircut you know and last time
I'd seen them they didn't have a you
know an uchi in their life and next
thing you know BAM here we are again and
they cared enough to bring it up to show
me you know because that was the
difference that last time his wife had
this bump you know she had that
gestation rocking you know she's rocking
those masters man there's trimesters you
know cuz you catch a strong hit of seed
ladies and you start editing it you
start egging it up and next thing you
know you with child and so it was just
cool man it was nice that then they took
it they took a special moment to come to
obviously get a sitter or to have one
that you know a parent or a stepparent
to watch the baby and they came out to
my show to spend some time with me and
then cared enough to show me that you
know say hey look this is what was going
on my life last time I saw you and and
then here we are again and it was cool
man they had a guy with uh who was
tweeting with me or DME before the show
saying he was nervous to meet me and
that made me feel I said I'm I
said well now I'm nervous to meet you
you know because now you mean you know
like now hug I feel like I'm gonna blind
date but yeah man a lot of special
people came out you know it was fun man
a lot of people that came out there were
fans of this podcast that were listeners
at this thing you know that we're doing
and it was trying to think of who else
came out that was special man they had a
young fella drove in with his mother and
that was nice to see you know because
I've never been to uh I mean I've been
to my mother's coming mount my own
comedy show before but just to go do
something with my mother my we hadn't
really done that yet you know but anyhow
it was fun man so thank you Jacksonville
for having me and and I will be back and
I just had a blast I had a blast just
being you know just to work or among
workers and I got to this club man you
can't have a big ego in a club like this
because we need all hands on deck in
that kind of a place you know and you
need everybody needs to show up with a
good attitude and that's what
get going because if you told me right
now okay we're gonna hollow out this
Walmart and put a cause small comedy
club in one corner of it I'd have been
like that's a horrible idea but if you
tell me today that we couldn't do with
that I'd say well we just did it this
weekend and we had a blast so thank you
guys for coming out to that show
i watch that cormier fight that Cormier
node's mere oh oh I think it's ODEs
mirror and I don't know if you know
about this Daniel Cormier but he's a
Louisiana guy and at first you think
he's a chef oak or Daniel Cormier he
makes those uh he makes his expensive TV
dinners no Daniel Cormier is a cage
fighter prizefighter
and he was out there and he's a national
champion he has one of the title belts
and he's out there and I don't know if
you've seen his bombing this guy you
can't tell from watching if he's 6 foot
4 or 5 foot 1 he has like a very unique
body style like I mean like the thigh
bones connected to the neck bone you
know you're like what like he looked
just look like a like a um he looks like
a really strong caramel that somebody
taught to fight and he's out there and
he kind of fights with both arms like
he's just has this it's almost like he's
damn it's a bit of a dance in a way and
look I'm not this man would beat my ass
this man would this man would finish me
off like a drumette you know this man
would suck me down like a meat drumette
but he was out there Daniel Cormier and
he's um and he kind of he kind of he'll
like punch with both of his arms at the
same time so it's almost like this this
wave of aggression that was coming at
odhh Zamir and owed Zamir is a I mean
this guy he could have been nah he could
have been he could have been 11 feet
tall dude I don't know what ratio I had
my screen on it might have been sixteen
by nine or something so I don't know but
odes Mira look like a damn whoo
like the youngest son of a polar bear he
looked like a lean polar bear like
somebody just beat just like something
like a polar bear that's worked out so
hard all his fur fell off and he just
got real lean and he had the long leg
white legs just like damn you know like
you don't even and he got that name odes
Amir let me see what it's how it even Oh
is dimmer dimmer OHS dimmer so dude and
you're sitting there trying to figure
out his name he's trying to buy a vowel
and then damn he hits you his arms one
of his arms looking like it was probably
four and a half feet long and he just
hits you with one of those polar pops
just patio you know he just hit you with
that polar pop and next thing you know
you ice cold next thing you know you
waking up in the frozen food section out
there and out east of the city and
you're ringing the bell for help over at
the bakery section because nobody's
paying attention any anything in the
grocery store and it's late night hours
and you just got polar popped by mr.
ODEs mere and you woke up out there in
the frozen food section
but Cormier you know you could see how I
mean the first round and when you looked
at him if the confidence that Cormier
moves with is what got me and O'Connell
I don't know it's not about fighting I
don't claim to know I used to not even
like to watch these fights watching them
made me feel a little bit scared like
that's how much of a puss I am sometimes
when it comes to you know being out in
these streets is watching a real tough
fight I mean I put on knee pads or
something even from just watching at the
house you know I checked my PPO if I was
even just watching at the house but you
had Cormier out there and there you know
like and at first the first like two
minutes three minutes it was all punches
I mean then I loved it it was like
watching two men that could do other
stuff choosing to punch choosing to box
I mean it looked like gladiator style
stuff you know a couple of lights um you
know a couple of like placement kicks
and trying to keep each other this way
in that way you know look like a little
bit of polish dancing here and there but
a lot of punches being thrown and
I mean just man were you standing
up there and still punch and even though
you gettin punched and then they went it
out into the ground and I thought I was
gonna be over cuz uh odes Mir has one of
his legs just popped straight out like a
white flag I thought he's trying to
surrender with his foot and I thought
he's trying to wave that foot out there
and then the Bell saved the gentleman
and so they came out back out for the
second that second start that second
round and it was almost the first round
and it was like somebody press fast
forward in the first round and before
you know it Cormier had him down on the
ground
and just a series of punches you're like
man it was just uh I mean I almost liked
him Cormier tell like I don't if you
ever heard that story of John Henry the
steel-driving man but it was a long time
ago they have this you know they have
this old story um I'm gonna look it up
right now it was when it was a long time
ago it's a folk hero and he worked as a
steel-driving man as him was John Henry
and he was the best if you put that man
in the cave with the hammer he was the
best and he would just beat up the rock
and he would get all through the rock
and do whatever he had to do and then
one day they came along with a machine
and they said well this machine can do
this job we don't need you to work
anymore John Henry and John Henry said I
can beat that machine and I don't
remember if he beats the Machine or not
but I know he dies trying and that's
what I rounded me a cornea man he just
started putting this kind of punch this
and it was a slow organized systematic
punch it was like it was like when you
are knocking it say your girlfriend's
cheating on you and you know she's in
there with a man and you already took a
few deep breaths in the car because
you're not really into her anymore
you're past her but you still gonna go
in there and deal with that man so you
take a few deep breaths maybe do some
light meditation maybe get the headspace
app or something and use that for a
minute before you head up to the door
and you're gonna knock on that door
and you knock on that door just because
that knock is gonna resonate different
with your old lady in that man back
there plugging at each other's parts you
know Hyde and inside of the you
look you're at your wife or whatever if
he's doing you know back there a
freaking hiding because a bang bang
bang that's your attic they're gonna
jump up you know somebody might try to
get out of window block you know my
somebody might try to hide under a pile
of dirty clothes did I did that one time
tried to hide under a pile of dirty
clothes dude Oh first of all I think
some of the clothes was like a baby's
dirty blanket or something you ever had
a man Beach harassing Apollo dirty
clothes then you haven't really really
lived probably and that happened that
actually happened over near Tallahassee
in Florida that was a long time ago but
I've had my ass beat and a pile of dirty
clothes man and you and that will humble
you that will humble you right there boy
him in the when a big boy put
you on the you know introduces
you to that too arm spin cycle and
suddenly you know he's beating the dirt
off he all he's beating the dirt off he
all man he's doing that laundry on you
but that's how this was it was almost
like he liked going up to the door of
your ex when you know she's in there
your girl you know she's in there with a
man and just that slow knock because you
know that you're gonna be you are in
control of this situation you know
you're gonna get in there you gonna
whoop some ass you're not gonna do it
erratically though cuz you don't need
the relationship anymore you passed it
but you're still gonna get in there and
beat some ass and that's how Cormier
just rocked him with this hand it was
just a slow planned thing he just knew
his execution was it was so efficient
and it was it was uniquely efficient
because he's he's an awkwardly built man
and I don't say that's a judge him I
mean dude I'm bill did I built
like a little bit like a beat-down
syndrome if you catch me you know I you
know in the realms beyond when the Lord
was forming me I mean it I was like a
Plinko chip and almost went
I could have fallen into that D
at the bottom but instead I got barely
regular but uh but Cormier just a unique
guy you know I mean his thumb joints
connected to his you know to his calf I
mean he's just this I mean he's just
this nasty he's just nasty caramel out
there that's gonna that's gonna
stick you to the mat that's gonna it's
gonna gum up your teeth and stick you to
the mat and I and I like to watching
them after I liked watching their press
conferences after - because you could
tell Cormier he said you know I forty
years old I'll be done fighting he's 38
years old now and look I I when I watch
these men fight I watched him do
something that I could never do I do not
have the spinal column of the balls to
do that I could fight somebody for
charity you know I'm saying I could
probably beat up a real ginger I could
probably beat up a real lean ginger for
charity and I'm not talking about ginger
a woman's name I'm talking about a
redheaded fella you know or a strong
woman I fight a strong woman if they we
got the contracts and everything
and everybody's clean I'll need all the
gender stuff but man
Cormier after he said you know I'm 38
now and by 40 I won't be doing this so
you could he said you know when you
prepared so much exactly in a sea his
preparation go exactly as planned and
you believe that with him you just
believed it you believed he knew his
plan he came in and he just did exactly
what his plan was and it was gonna work
or it wasn't gonna work but you saw a
man who was who had been in his craft
and been in his realm for a long time
you know and that he knew he wasn't
gonna waste time he needed this
opportunity he wanted to win he wanted
to defend his title and he wanted to get
the most out of his career while he
still could so he'd worked hard and
planned ahead and made the most of his
opportunity that's what I gathered from
listening to it now I'm also no expert
I'm no expert at all and if you want to
be like the oh you are a you're a
muppet you don't know and you would
probably you probably be right
but I'll say this about Daniel Cormier
that man has built like a damn shiver
robe with a bad attitude that man is
built like a like a shiver robe and a
grizzly bear had had a baby and
he will in the he will just I mean I
thought he could smother somebody I
wouldn't be some he'll put he could put
two kids to sleep just by putting one
under each arm these children don't
arrest giving him a hit of
dimetapp or that tussin just popped that
him
put him on up on her daddy's chest meat
and they'd be out I mean dude I bet he
could damn he could panini press could
press a sandwich dude he could make a
panini right there up against his rib
cage with his own wing and he seemed
like that kind of man but also it was
cool to listen to this ODEs mere kid and
I said kid he's an eel probably 11 feet
tall and he looks at a ladder and he's
like yeah whatever guy I'm not taking it
easy today this man could be as he could
do his own work and he said he was so
young he said he'd been fighting for a
year or so and suddenly he was at the
title and he thought that he would be
back at the title and he also seemed he
one thing that was really interesting to
me that was cool about him that made him
seem very human was that he said while
I'm in Boston and tomorrow I'm gonna try
to get out and go see the city and I
thought that that was you know I wish I
could have that kind of attitude
sometimes you know when something rough
has happened to me or something that
didn't go I mean this guy I just had a
chance to win a a belt a gold belt I
mean you don't get a chance to win a
gold belt unless you were in you know
unless you you know fist fighting a
up there on Beverly Hills
Boulevard one of these fancy belt shops
or unless you're in the WWE or the UFC
or unless you're in ancient Egypt those
only those only you don't get to
fistfight nobody for a gold belt and and
he said you know any laws he did he
didn't win but he was like well I'm here
in Boston I'm gonna say I'm gonna go see
the city tomorrow I'm gonna put on some
sunglasses and i'ma go see some of the
city and I thought that that was pretty
cool that he was going to take some
away because look man one thing and I'm
slowly learning is that if i'ma lose
i'ma learn I learned something I'm
taking something out of this out of this
swamp I'm taking something out of this
swamp you know you might get me in here
and it might be nasty and dirty I might
almost drown I might take an L but I'm
leaving out of here with a beautiful
piece of birch I'm gonna learn something
but that was some cool stuff that went
on man that fight being in Jacksonville
sorry if I'm rambling guys I got real
coffee today you know I'm trying to
stealth him cured pods and I've talked
about that I got that real coffee coming
back in I'm excited to tell you too that
uh I want to thank the patreon
supporters we got a new website that's
um being put together so we can get more
interactive here some man I'm just
grateful I'm so grateful you know we got
a lot of cool stuff happening yeah it's
just gonna be fun and we're gonna do
some fun stuff I got some fun dates
coming up I'll be at Harveys in Portland
February 8th through the 11th and those
tickets are on sale now also we're
trying to set up a video to go do we got
a hamster rancher that reached out and
you a lot of you guys know that I grew
up in the game you know I was in you
know selling HAMP's G pigs out there off
of Ali Road over there in st. Tammany
Parish and and this man does it he's
caught up in that and so we're gonna try
to do a special video where we go out
and meet this hamster Rancher and see
what the life's like out there when he
out there if they still using these big
little baby bottles or you know we had
these like kind of drip rails where we
put the put some cold milk and water all
in these drip rails and then it would
just hold the drop onto the bottom of
the rail and then the you know all these
little offspring could come up and just
drink right off the rail that's how we
used to feed them February 16th through
18th I'll be at La Jolla in California
at the Comedy Store La Jolla set 22nd
through the 24th I'll be an Indio at
fantasy Springs casino if you want to
gamble and Lou
your money but also still laugh for a
little bit fantasy Springs a fun place
to do that March 15th and 16th I'll be
in Tacoma at the comedy club and that's
in Washington March 17th and Spokane
April 6 and 7th Tampa Florida at Rock
Brothers brewing that's two nights and
we're also getting Chicago on the books
so I'm trying to figure out where to do
that if you know a neat theater or
something in Chicago that's not too big
and I'm saying we ain't selling out the
world you know so we need an intimate
experience so it could be a theater or a
place where they have comedy shows
that's kind of you know medium-size
maybe seats 100 150 or - 200 maybe let
me know and we'll see what we can do
trying to do something cool there also
take it if you will if you want to email
me and some trying to put together some
art for a dark arts tour and some dark
art shirts and you know what kind of
that's sort of become the vibe you know
people been reaching out about the dark
arts and trying to stay in them and
trying to stay out of them you know and
I mean I got caught up this weekend in
this motel and it was a hotel actually
but but I forgot to say hotel when I
started talking about it a second ago
and dude something about a hotel I don't
know what they if they put like a
something in the carpet that just makes
you masturbate but damn if they've you
know some of the patterns in the carpet
I feel like you know you're walking down
the hall and next you know you get
hypnotized by the carpet pattern next
you know you jerking off and ordering
Stromboli or something from a local
Italian eatery and next thing you know
it's two days later and it's just
something about you know I ah I do not
do well man I don't do well when I get
into some of those hotels and motels and
I just get to you know I'll get the
depression this gets in me and I get
caught up and I just getting a bad cycle
you know my day would be a lot better if
I could just get off to that strong
start and that's where I need to really
try and do some work and I don't know if
that means investing in a trainer you
know or what it means but
I gotta I gotta do something cause if I
can get good when I get going I'm going
I'm going onward and I don't do bad but
I just I just need a stronger start but
when I look at my life I've always been
a late bloomer and so it doesn't
surprise me that that strikes me often
daily but those are some dates we have
coming up and and you can always go to
Theo von comm slash store if you want to
grab this past weekend on work shirt or
we got some other ones on there you
ain't got the balls to grow the falls
the hair is growing out and I'm gonna
get it actually cut up and tighten up
this weekend from a boy John it was a
long distance by cyclists not homosexual
guy and he's long distance by cyclist
and I'm gonna go over there and uh and
get caught up by him get trimmed up and
tightened up what else man I want to get
into some other things oh I want to talk
I do want to talk about the football
games I know you know it's gonna be
brief here you know it's and I'm sorry
to those Jacksonville fans it's tough
man it's tough to see that but you got a
beautiful community over there of you
know people that were kind of brought
together you know they had a dude last
night it was supposed to be a spoke be
in a wheelchair but I guess it family
and Hannah and have a lot of money they
put him in a souped up high chair you
know like a babies highchair but he they
had it rocked out with some you know
some fours on there some fives you know
5 inch wheels and and I you know at
first I was like damn what the but
then it brought me back to this is the
kind of environment that I grew up in
you know people out here my me dude we
had this group bus hoover's and one of
the brothers is uh physically
handicapped and he couldn't walk or
Nothing you know he wasn't doing any
walking or they never taught him how to
walk maybe because it looked like he
could walk now that I really think about
it but maybe they never taught him out
of Walt because he lived in that kind of
household because at certain levels of
poverty in certain levels of you know
trickle down
you know lack of trickle-down economics
your family you know the most basic
things are gonna be tough for you and
they had one brother and he the older
boy would just put him on his back
wear him on his back like a backpack
because the older boy was one of the
strongest kids I've ever seen you know
didn't he one of his teeth was like four
teeth and one like that kind of dude
like like super strong probably
didn't even probably didn't even sleep
probably stayed awake forever until if
he if he's dead then he's gone now but
probably always stayed awake that kind
of person
you know tattoos he had a bunch of
tattoos didn't know where he got them
tattoos that had nothing to do with him
you know you know r.i.p Angelyn you're
like who's Angela's like I don't know
and I can you know somebody knew
long enough to hold you down and write
it on you you know you think you got
more Intel when that was going on but he
used to wear his brother on his back his
brother that couldn't walk so I've been
around that type of he'd wear him on his
back like a backpack just hold both of
his arms on his chest and his be rocking
his brother you know his brother was you
know let head of that limp he was limp
from the waist down kind of dude they
had this one brother by me this black
guy and his legs he had something real
lean legs you know not a lot of muscular
a bone in there he might have had zero
bone he might had that mermaid
ISM or something with zero bone in his
legs and he got him armor on one time
for graduation dude he got his legs
braided he had his hair braided
cornrowed and he had his legs
braided around each other I was like
damn man that's gangster as when
you braiding your appendages just to
look nice for something so you know it
just that was another thing about
Jacksonville just took me back to just
being in regular time then I saw this
man who was in this you know kind of
cooped out high chair you know this baby
eatery and him and his buddy was sitting
there and they talking about the game
and they were so excited and you could
tell I don't know if you could tell that
they hadn't had a lot of excitement
in their life but there is something
about a team doing well that brings
people together and that you know you
know when you see somebody then we're in
the same emblem as you even if it's a
trademark it's a national football team
whatever sports does that for people it
brings people together and I was sorry
to see Jacksonville lose because
emeritus II in Boston win you know I
even added a Boston fan and if there's a
Boston fan out there who can tell me
more about this that that they're tired
of seeing the Patriots win cuz I bet at
some point it does have to get a little
do you feel greedy and I'm not saying
you like you are like you're taking the
victory every year but you are you're
achieving it does it still at a certain
point feel like it's what does that feel
like
I don't maybe greed isn't the word but
what does that feel like I'm curious
about that if you feel and like you know
what let's let's let somebody else do it
you know it'd be nice to let see
somebody else do it and then Minnesota
they lost that game and they got they
asked what by the Philadelphia Eagles
and I apologize I've I don't think
there's a nicer stretch of people in
America kinder people than in Minnesota
I really don't and I think there's a lot
of kind people out there but you you
know they even have a thing called
Minnesota nice where people are just so
nice that they don't even know what's
going on you know some guy died a couple
years ago there because he had just been
so nice to people know like what
happened to him like he he just
nice tout you know they find they find
they found him and he'd been just niced
he'd just been nice to death just just
too nice
like damn mm-hmm but but I was talking
to Shai Chris who is uh the assistant
who's helping out here in the pod here
and he is uh and he's a Latino gentleman
and he was saying he said well you know
what the thing about Minnesota was they
didn't really they didn't get a team win
last week they got they won the game but
it was just a player beat a player at
that last minute that last second
and it didn't feel like a team win so
you had a team in there in the NFC
championship that that had accidentally
gotten there it seemed like and I'm not
trying to discredit Minnesota but that
made sense to me it was like it felt
like their team didn't win that game but
that they they slip by so then you have
to think about it then you have a team
that that worked their way into their
Philadelphia and you have a team that it
seemed like kind of slipped in and so
it's really tough for that team that
slipped in you know because of you know
the the minute and miracle in Minnesota
if it took a miracle to get you there
then what's it gonna take to get you
passed through that next game you know a
team miracle you know what's it gonna
take
Philadelphia you gotta be in a plane
crash like what would it have taken for
them to get to that next game but my
team's out so obviously I'm sour the
Saints suck that you know the Saints ate
it and their coaches out there I think
on them perks and he's out there dancing
and doing all of this in that and uh I
don't know I'm just I guess pissed that
my team's out but that's your Super Bowl
it's gonna be Boston verse Philadelphia
bad accent bad accent boy man that's
gonna be fun I'm excited I'm excited for
that game I think it's gonna be good I
also think that's what else is good is
that great block pizza and great bought
pizzas our charter sponsor and I
couldn't be more grateful to have a
group come on board and help us and get
us and feed feed the need in all of us
to have that hit a great block piece
that their link will be in the
information the woman's March came in
that thing came in hot and and we had a
call that came in and I'm gonna get to
start slowly start to get to some of
these and here was one of them right
here that kind of came in talking about
Aziz Ansari and I haven't listened to
any of the calls I do look through
because they are trans they're
transposed on
on the voicemail service but so I can
see sometimes vaguely what they say or
if it's somebody that I recognize it
it's called or if it's somebody that
needs some you know direct you know
friendship but uh but I don't know um
but I'm trying not to listen to them so
I can hear him firsthand here we go
hey Theo this is Jessica from Salt Lake
City hey Jessica in Salt Lake and I've
had a lot of people reach out from Salt
Lake to say come to town and the owner
of that club they're wise guys this man
Keith Stubbs he uh he sent me a direct
message yesterday after I've tagged him
in about 20 tweets over the past two
years and he said hey man let's see
about getting you in for a weekend so
we're gonna try to make that happen
there and I'm grateful about that let's
hear more calling in about these I'm
sorry
and his allegations yep Aziz Ansari had
the big sexual allegations last week and
he seems to have you know he got off the
hook on him I don't know how heavy the
allegations were it seemed like a woman
had just recounted what to some people
would just call a bad date or a sexual
experience that she decided afterwards
that she didn't really like and maybe
during she decided she didn't like but
he didn't get that same impression and
whether that's because he isn't keen to
getting impressions from people which I
wouldn't be surprised or whether he it
was just whatever it was just a regular
date and he didn't think anything of it
what's your more maybe instead of
bringing up things that we may or may
not know to be true maybe don't bring
them up and I'm saying this because you
guys already feel isolated enough we
don't need to be addressing things that
we know cannot be an issue or and or be
true okay so I'm thinking you're saying
that you know if we're not sure the
truth then let's don't talk about it
that's you know and look I feel you it's
a little bit scary to talk about stuff
when you don't know the facts you
allottee on it yet you don't know when
there's no real jurisdiction on it but
then part of that is what what we do in
the world we talk about stuff we
communicate about it mm-hmm
you know we're afraid of me the first
time I talked about Aziz thing on the
show I was afraid to say that I felt
like whenever I met him a couple times
that I met him he was a dick that he
wasn't friendly that he was one of the
only people that ever shook my hand and
didn't look at me when he did it while
he was being introduced to me um you
know that made me feel kind of less than
you know it made me but then some of
that could just be my own maybe
that's just Hollywood maybe that's just
the way it is but I was afraid to kind
of say that because sometimes I get
afraid to say to say what you know
I guess I get worried about the
repercussions in my business well you
know this guy's talking bad about
comedians talking bad about this or that
yeah but I think sometimes we just we
try and talk about stuff but yeah maybe
bringing it up wasn't it wasn't that
good I'm curious to hear if you tell me
more about why you think that homeward
perhaps maybe we should think about
things that are going on with the Miche
movement that I'm being addressed like
people not being charged for these
outrageous transit they have committed
the mom Leslie brand miss Ephesus was
created a divide in between me and my
spouse where he feels isolated my filled
neglected in regards to these types of
issues they're finally being brought to
light or we're looking over here saying
well what about this guy what did he do
it's just another distraction ah and
that could be another distraction look
I'll say this and I'm working in
Hollywood I'm trying to make a career
for myself here I would not put anything
past Hollywood I wouldn't put it past
him because it's too big of a money
machine for Hollywood not to you know
push and pull punches the way that they
need them to be pushed and pulled yeah I
wouldn't be surprised if
I'm sure I would well I'm not sure I
would bet that somebody said off Aziz is
way too big of a moneymaker
you know it's wet there's way too many
wagons hooked to this Pony for him to go
down if he goes down man he's him you
know he's in me I think he's an Emmy
winner you know he's got a hit series he
sold out Madison Square Garden that is a
lot of money if he goes down we are
P some people are sitting there
looking say we're financially
we're not or what it's not gonna
make that extra loot so of course then
you reach out to a writer you know of
you know some a PR person and you say
look this allegation came out what's a
neat way that we can frame this or
what's another angle we can show of this
to put out there to get people to think
bigger or get people think differently
or get people to at least see both sides
of it and now I'm not saying that Aziz
was guilty of anything he may not have
been when I read back on and I look at
just the elements that we know about it
seems like he was a dude that was trying
to that was trying to get laid she
seemed like a young lady who probably of
who statistically just based on their
the lengths of time they've been alive
wasn't able to hook up with a lot of
dudes probably so you know maybe hadn't
been in this type of environment to seem
like the first celebrity kind of guy
she'd been around or been with and he
you know did he use his power I don't
know I don't think so it doesn't seem
like he liked it didn't seem like he was
like I'm Aziz Ansari me it just
seems like he was being a dude trying to
bang or trying to catch an in trying to
catch some nut magic and she was a young
girl who didn't really know what was
going on and then I think a lot of girls
are confused now as to even well if I
just had a bad date do I my supposed to
complaint and my supposed to nut it
might not complain what am I supposed to
say that
what if has had a bad date four years
ago dude I remember being young this
girl first time I got a jerked
me off into this river and the fish all
came in eights a bunch of
a bunch of my damn semen you know what
I'm sorry for being dirty here and
talking about like this but I remember
busting out first time I ever busted out
in front of a woman and the fish come
right up there have it all and I
remember thinking I was gonna go to hell
dude
but do I come out now and say that this
girl beat me off into a river and try to
you know demoralize me by making me feel
that I was feeding fish with my body
make I don't know I don't think so so
it's just but if don't you know but if I
was under this but if I was a girl and
the roles were switched and there was
this me to movement I might think that I
might think well I had a weird
experience I gotta share mine I think
it's just vague and when things get
vague and things are vague that's when
there's a lot of wiggle room and
unfortunately in this type of
environment is a lot of wiggle room
where people can get careers can get
damaged but yeah they could easily
you know maybe they push that envelope a
little bit with somebody big to take the
onus off of more important celebrities
and more important issues let's hear
more I'm sorry to you know talk on your
time here Jessica really AM homework
maybe let's talk about how Harvey
Weinstein Kevin Spacey and all of them
have yet to even be charged it says
given coverage just some chick they did
you give what she's talking about
okay and that's a good point yeah it's
like we're talking about this weird date
maybe that this guy went on or a bad
date but then you have these you know
you have real men over here who are not
being charged with real crimes and I
think the thing there is that those are
real crimes and there's nothing slower
in America than justice or the you know
the legal system and I think you could
see a while before I think those charges
are probably being packaged if you will
you know and they're they're crossing
you know probably legally they're
crossing all their T's and eyes dot in
their eyes or cross in their eyes if
they're idiots and they're
probably putting those packages together
to make those charges yeah because those
are bigger things you know those are
bigger things but yeah you had that yeah
you had the woman's March this weekend
and and I you know I mean I've said this
before you know I grew up a single mom I
remember my mom got fired my mother had
a decent job at one point where she was
making some money and her boss uh was
mean to her mistreated her you know
really talked down to her and my mother
complained to above her boss she
complained to her boss's boss both of
whom were men and my mom got fired she
got fired and then after that we we did
go into some tougher times because it
was right after she had her fourth child
and uh and I just think it was a lot on
her I think it broke her spirit some and
that's when my parents got divorced and
stuff and I just think that you know so
I'll stand behind any woman that is
trying to make their lives better
there's nothing that's you know strained
me personally in my life more than then
uh then see him you know women not be
allowed to feel comfortable and be
themselves but this March to me this
weekend it seemed like a it seemed like
a cute sign festival palme honest if I'm
looking on Instagram this time all of it
seems of you know kind of a guy selling
its good idea
get together but it also seemed like a
cute sign festival who can make the
cutest sign you know also sometimes in a
lot of this stuff when it's vague to me
there's a lot of room for anybody can
get in there you know a lot of people
just trying to make money a lot of
celebrities show up to those things they
got to get their women's March thing in
because that's their that's their uh
that's their avenue for tomato to make
cash you know that's I mean feminism the
feminism movement and some fit mean
there's some there's some feminists that
it's just a this is a cash
game to them and that's unfortunate but
I think that smart women can see that
and smart men can see that and and so I
think if that if those are some of the
outliers of things that happen that you
have these you know people taking
advantage of the system
for there to be for young women to feel
empowered and feel like it feels
stronger to have a voice and I think
that's good but I think it's unhealthy
when you raise when I feel like there's
a lot of women out there who are being
just young women who are being told that
that that they're that men are bad that
men are bad and I just feel that I see
that as being not healthy long term
because a lot of just angry women out
there you also have a lot of lesbians
out there who were like out there being
like men you know well yeah you're
gonna say that you're a lesbian
you have no interest in men like we're
it are there any less means they're like
yeah men are okay no cuz they trying to
catch that split there is a lot of
lesbian a lot of lesbians are just
undercover men and you know a lot of
them are out there and these what in
these you know in these streets in these
DC hotel rooms catching these wild
plastic parties and doing all of that
after these marches it's like of
bringing sweaty legs up into 3:19 you
know and I washed your legs off in the
tub with some Abbi on water and use one
of these big electric powered wieners on
you and doing things like that so just
be what I mean look you just got to be
wise and everything but I think a lot of
people see what's going on you know I
think there's a lot of people you know
if there's a woman out there who got her
sitter for her kids you know or had made
her husband watch them and said I want
to go out there and walk and feel some
empowerment man that's awesome you know
I want to go and see what it feels like
to be around a bunch of women and feel
good but it also seem like a lot of
stuff out there people didn't know what
it was for some people out there just
hate and Trump some people out there
post
50 instagrams trying to get the cute fun
they're cute a sign that they could you
know and so I think it's just it was
just mixed but then maybe that's what it
supposed to be maybe the women artists
marching but a lot of women arguing to
us on social media about what the whole
cause was and that was hilarious
because he used have a bunch of women
arguing in the street about what they're
they're even to to discuss or what
they're they're even to talk about but
it was interesting I appreciate you
calling Jessica let's go to another call
here man let's do that we're here let's
do it hey Co there's a new app out now
it's similar to those apps similar to a
goober they have this other app I
believe it's called soothe and it's for
massages so you enter your location and
a certified masseuse massage therapist
will come to your house and give you a
massage that you had orders do the app
oh wow I appreciate this call she's
saying you can get a massage off an app
so you can get a pizza and somebody to
you know come over and touch
your trapezius is all in a couple of
clicks of a button
let me hear more about this man sounds
sounds questionable to me
anyway she didn't think it was a good
idea she actually thought it was quite
dirty
she thought the app would be used for
sexual pleasures and whatnot and we got
into a little bit of an argument over I
said it's for working professionals and
busy people and she thinks just another
outlet or excuse for creeps to have
dirty massages come to their door I
think it could be I think it could be
but it could be what we're headed to you
know if you have to have documentation
you have to have people sign off on a
release to touch each other anymore it
could be what we're headed to you know
there's probably gonna be a special you
know some guy pedaling around a special
bathtub or something you got to even
jerk off in watch it watch two years
from now there's gonna be like a meter
on your drain and no jerk-off can go
down there and if you jerk off you got
to do it into a special tub and they got
a you know a couple of men biking
bicycling these tubs around and some of
these men might be like
Teno man and am i judging them but let's
be honest said Latino the Latino
population keeps America afloat
dude this this country is rich red white
and beige let's be honest and so that'd
be probably pretty wild it might be
pretty cool you know your boy Javier
pulls up and it's you tip him five bucks
to look the other way and he you know
it's mono e mono he respects the fact
that this is the way it is now that
you're not allowed to you know sexually
you know feel any desires anymore as a
man so you have to just you know and
he's just running that seed tub and it's
just you know and there's a lot of
respect there I could almost see that
being that that being a beautiful film
you know where maybe there's somebody
that lives out in the and you know in a
field or something somewhere on the edge
of town you know out in the country and
he's at a you know but Javier still
bikes that tub out there and cycles that
you know that septic --all he just he
still cycles that septic allowed there
so the man you know can you know jerk
off a couple more times you know and
still feel like a man a little bit and
they talk about manhood real
low-key and and then you know and then
Javier cycles back in and that's it I
come home it's almost like a kind of
like a new-age kind of Dances with
Wolves you know huh I don't know what's
gonna happen but yeah I don't look I
think yeah a lot of women be using that
to sell sex but that's what's happening
now I mean look if you don't think that
the sex selling trade is going on it's
going on I mean you go to backpage.com
and find you an escort any day of the
week now I will tell you that the ladies
on there that you see in the pictures
are not the ladies that aren't gonna
come to your door it's gonna be a
different lady okay that's gonna be a
different lady what they gonna show you
on the website is gonna be Johnston and
Murphy and what kind of show up at your
door is gonna be more like Totino's you
see what I'm saying you're gonna get a
different product
so does beware but what I do think is
neat about I was history just chiming
back in on that woman's March for a
second if you're a young girl and you
see a lot of women getting
there and doing something and feeling
empowered as a young I think that would
be neat you know if my sisters or
whatever saw that when we were kids you
know say we're you know and it's fun and
it looks neat but I don't I don't know
if it's if it looks neat when it's a
bunch of women out there you know just
yelling blaming everything in the world
on blaming all the sexism and everything
in the world on Donald Trump and blaming
it on white people I mean there's a lot
of racist going on out there you
know a lot of white people blaming white
people for do don't do that
I'm so sick of that I'm so sick of it
and it's mostly entitled white people
they're now gonna try to flip the script
and blame they're blaming poor white
people too but everything is red and
white people redneck white people's
fault are the most racist people in the
world that's dude and I'm
saying I grew up around those people and
nobody a lot of times helped more people
in art too in our town and in our
neighborhood that had different color
and their skin then the people that
you're saying are pieces of
so some of those get so sick of that man
because there's nothing more racist than
saying that oh just because someone's
poor and white and they live off of a
highway or they don't or they you know
are they you know we're in the 4-h club
suddenly they're a racist you're a
idiot if you think that that's
narrow-minded that's just as
narrow-minded as me thinking that a
whole group is one way it's the same
thing it's the same thing if there's
something different I'd love to hear a
different note on that cuz maybe and you
can tell them I I'm agitated by it I can
feel it in my chest I can feel my neck
starting to think you know my neck is
starting to think a little bit you ever
get that when you feel agitated you feel
your neck start thinking your necks like
damn but some of this stuff you know
some of these women are just out there
trying to take all the blame off of them
well we did oh you're a white woman you
have never done any you never you know
see a lot of white privilege running
around out there
trying to pretend behind different signs
that they're not involved in it you know
and everybody claiming that you know
just I don't know and I'm off the handle
here but you know what I don't know if
I've ever been on the handle oh pretty
fun news story right here I'll tell you
surgeon caught tagging people's liver
during surgery and that is some
straight-up G right there
Simon Bramhall was caught signing his
name on to livers that he was performing
surgery on he was supposed to be
stopping the liver from bleeding but
couldn't help but leave his mark after a
job well done Simon claims no bodily
harm was done to patient but the court
didn't see it that way and he was
charged with assault causing actual
bodily harm and was fined 10,000 British
pounds come on I mean if somebody died
yes lock him up
but if he's just out there tagging up a
couple of organs did he sound like he
just went they sound like he grew up in
Tucson Arizona you know I remember when
I was I went to school in Tucson for a
semester over at Santa Rita high school
out there in Tucson and and half of our
class they were these young you know and
this it was a lot of it was mostly
Hispanic it was mostly Mexican a lot of
dude half of our class would be outside
it's pretty Peyton their homework
onto the side of the building like I did
looking less than four right here miss
and just be just tagging up the whole
side of the building I mean I somebody
wrote a whole term paper on the side of
a car wash next door and so maybe that's
what this dude was doing you know I
think it's kind of innovative I think
it's kind of neat if they could do what
though like what's he writing it with if
he's writing with a scapula you know
where something sharp that's probably
dangerous but hey man whatever you got
to do was he putting on Instagram if
he's not putting on Instagram I don't
even count so
yeah man what else dude oh the
government shutdown good let it shut
down for a little bit I'm gonna be fine
you know why because I'm able to take
care of myself I have a job that's it I
don't need the government man if we shut
down some of these news media outlets I
think maybe we'll be able we can finally
find some peace in our day I don't know
who has more blood on their hands
sometimes you know this interfaith to me
this government's been inefficient for
40 years man rich getting richer poor
aren't really being helped don't really
being inspired but I do feel like
there's a little more inspiration out
there these days so that is good you
know and also I don't know
I don't know and also I didn't get much
sleep last night I got up in
Jacksonville this morning 5 a.m. caught
that flight here to Los Angeles one more
news story ultra runner wins marathon by
hiding in a bathroom
Kelly Agnew or a record holder for the
white rim trail and runner up at the
2013 Pony Express trail 100 found guilty
of hiding inside of a port-a-potty
during the race and then when everybody
went by cutting corners hitting that
into the race popping out that
and catching that medallion and this I
mean I remember during Mardi Gras a lot
of they had a lot of homeless people or
just people that were alcoholics which
sleep in the is out at Mardi
Gras at night oh sorry just had to clear
my throat and caught a whole Easter of
just snot I think could had a pearl in
it boy did I could have put that thing
on a cracker
put a little bit of lemon on it a little
bit of horseradish a little bit of Pony
sauce that white sauce lit my
eyeballs up make my dick think about me
that's how I like to have moisturize
like that but this dude he was hiding
man hiding in a popped out
caught that Maddow
and trying to win the race and that's
you know you get busted you get busted
doing that you cut in corners
you're hiding in dude that's
what you get I just want to let you know
that that's what's going on out there
that's what's going on out there what's
also going on is that your business
might need a new higher e and here's an
important one every business should
consider if they are looking for an
employee make your hiring process more
efficient and effective this past year
2017 this year let's zip recruiter help
no one has done a better job of
transforming how you find the right
talent then they have zip recruiter
actively actively not passively not just
from a park bench or from a distance
with binoculars but actively on the
front lines they actively look for the
most qualified candidates and invite
them to apply no wonder 80% of employers
who post on zip recruiter employers get
a quality candidate through the site in
just one day basically they're that
conduit you put what you need on there
they put it out to everyone everyone
gets back to them they filter and give
you the best candidates for your
position and right now our listeners can
post jobs on zip recruiter for free
that's right for free just go to zip
recruiter dot-com slash tpw that's zi p
r e crui ter zip recruiter com /t p w I
had this email come in and and I want to
read it right now this is an email said
hey Theo I'd like to call in but I'm a
little too nervous and quite frankly
embarrassed I'm a young man 20 and a
half 20 and a half you know you're young
when you start still counting when you
still count in half remember that you're
like yeah I'm seven and a half whoa well
I'm nine in three-quarters man that was
fun
now I'm choppin out I try too
hot a year any way I can
but he said I'm 20 and a half and I'm
from Phoenix Arizona long story short
I'm not happy with my life situation at
the moment I'm thinking about dropping
out of school but I'm not sure how my
parents will feel about me doing so I
feel like school just isn't for me I
love to learn and have discussions in
class and I don't think of myself as an
idiot I've always gotten mediocre grades
which is always either disappointed or
shocked my teachers anyway I just feel
lost
I've changed my majors a few times
already and I just find myself staring
staring at back all over again every
semester starting back all over again
every semester sorry he didn't spell it
right and and I didn't read it right so
we both had kind of a part in that I'm
scared of how my friends and peers from
high school will think about me when I
see them at parties most importantly I
was scared of what my parents would
think of me the last thing I want to do
is disappoint them my dad came to this
country from Mexico and opened his own
business and of course he expects us to
be successful in life and of course that
means school what I truly want to do at
this point is drop out and start working
and save up to open my own business soon
I would really appreciate your feedback
and I'm also curious if you've ever
encountered these kinds of things when
you were in school
I appreciate you emailing Inman and his
name I believe it's Jose Ochoa this was
on the email I'm not sure if that's
right or not but I appreciate you
writing on it I know it is Oh Cho is his
last name mr. Ochoa I appreciate you
writing in have I encountered this yeah
it took me about 10 years to finish
college I went to a bunch of different
colleges and I didn't know for a while I
didn't think it was for me I almost took
that for me I took an angry sense of
pride and like man college isn't for
everyone you know look and that's true
it's not but for me it was I I didn't
think I was gonna finish and and so I
used that angle to make me feel better
about it you know if I'm some some
thinking I'm not gonna finish like
I don't know if I'm ever gonna finish
college then for me to be like oh man
everybody needs college then that's
easier and it's easier it's easier way
for me to digest it and to hold on to
what might be happening that I might not
be graduating and eventually I did and I
was glad that I did because it just took
it out of my life it took it it took it
out of my life and you know my mother
was a very educated woman she graduated
from Duke University second in her class
she was a smart lady you know she made
some you know some tough choices and she
had some tough choices to face so so at
least had that influence of college but
what made me want to really go to
college and get a degree and why I
decided to finish was a basketball coach
from when I was you know 11 and 12 years
old
this man mr. Steve coach Steve and
actually broke into his house a couple
years later just you know just being a
dumb kid and being ungrateful but he
told me he said you know why he goes you
got to get your diploma and I said why
and he said cuz they can't take it away
from you
that's what he said he said they can't
take it away from you and I didn't know
who they were and I still don't know who
they are but more and I so I got my
diploma and that was the reason it was
him saying that it was a man in my life
that took a moment to tell me something
and for some reason from that man I
could hear it you know my basketball
coach was one of the you know I've never
even gotten to play basketball until I
was 11 and so he put me on that team you
know and I made the little all-star team
in our town and it gave me like one of
the first senses of pride that I ever
felt as a child probably you know of
like um you know because he was a man
that cared enough he would come to pick
me up today me I got me
emotional man what the hell but he would
come to pick me up and take me to
practice you know and um and you know I
never had a man come and pick me up and
take me anywhere you know I'd never had
it and I just remember feeling like just
a lot of uh
you notice a lot of gratitude towards
him
you know maybe at the time I didn't now
I do looking back but I did I don't know
at the time I just I don't know it made
me feel good it made me feel a part of
something you know made me feel a part
of something you know he would pick me
up over in my neighborhood which is kind
of a shitty neighborhood he was taking
me over there to a nice gym where we
would practice and we want a city
championship our team and he knows and
it was just like things that made me
feel you know they made me feel like
every other kid you know that mean feel
okay they may feel a little bit of pride
you know I remember taking a hammer and
a nail and you know hammering up they
gave us a certificate that says City
champs on it and I remember just nailing
it into my wall you know right next to
this Jim McMahon poster and uh but but
anyway not to get too far face here but
he said he said you get your diploma he
goes because they can't take it away
from me and I didn't know who they were
but now when I look back I realized that
they for me they were me the the thing
in my head that tells me I never got it
done that's what it was it was they
can't take it away from you and also
it's it's it's people if no one can ever
say oh you didn't he didn't get a
diploma and so this would be my
suggestion for you and college is not
for everyone I just don't want you to be
quitting because because not because you
don't here's what I would say I think if
you got time to get it maybe try and get
it at your pace you know put a class on
the docket eat some look man and that's
what I did it took did I went to six or
seven different universities you know I
was taking I finally got my stuff
through University of New Orleans online
you know I finished up with a degree in
damn uh kerbin planning dude I'm a
neighborhood designer you know
but yeah
you get what you get you know and you
but they can't take it away from if you
get it so my suggestion to you would be
to map out a small plan even if it's a
ten-year plan and do that and get that
done because I think that you can I
think you can do it in over ten years
you can make it happen man
now I've had five years in or whatever
or in another two years you're
like that that's ridiculous it
doesn't work for me then okay that's it
you're done you don't need to you know
maybe it's not for you maybe you come
back later and you do it and you
mentioned a small business but I don't
have a plan as to what that business is
whatever you're doing I would have some
some semblance of a plan but at 20 years
old maybe you have time to get that or
get your associates or get something and
you could still go join the military for
you know a term or two I mean you still
have a lot of time to do a lot of things
so whatever you do I would have a little
try to have a little bit of a plan
I know it's hard at your age and it
might be tough to be honest with your
family and your friends but just tell
them you know have that same that same
message you wrote to me just talk to
your dad look I respect you more than
anything dad
you know I mean my father was first
general wait first generation from
Nicaragua you know when he came here and
um you know any worked hard he made a
lot of friends you know make any money
but I know that he found joy and a new
country and uh and I didn't know him
that much because he was so much older
so we don't have a lot of you know we're
not a lot of the same page there but but
I would just you know out here I'm just
rambling a little bit but I would have a
plan whatever you're gonna do at 20 I
think I would try and have a plan and
that's gonna be hard probably at 20 but
if you can start to have a plan now man
sky's the limit for you mr. Ochoa the
sky is the limit for you
but I commend you man it's certainly you
know you got a neat story and I think
that that's I always wanted to go live
in another country you know it was
always envious of people that just that
I cannot even imagine what your father
went through you know and my father for
that point but you
we're talking about your father right
now and just coming to a new place and
being so you know probably so scared but
also so inspired by the ability that
just knowing that if they had if he
worked hard that he had a chance because
that's what's missing in a lot of other
countries you know we sit here and a lot
of times people are marching and and
throwing up all this on social
media saying well what if this is going
on in this country and we need to help
it we need to solve it we'll go help it
go help it there's a woman getting rocks
thrown at her and I ran go hold a shield
up in front of her go do something you
know because you how we can help is by
people here achieving their dreams you
know and we're doing that you know like
a lot of the help a lot of the help that
America does is what's going on right
here you know and I know that's kind of
a vague segue right there but you get
out there man I'll cheer you on do those
are some thoughts that I have and also
bro if you don't like what I said you
ask take it for a grain of salt
I would ask five other people that you
trust and I would then I would just get
a look at some of their at some of their
thoughts and then I'd make your own
decision but they can't take it away
from you if you get it they can't take
it away you always have it and they for
me we're those question were those
people in the back of my head were my
own negative thoughts I would say oh you
didn't get you even get your diploma
well I got that thing I got that hitter
let's see we do one more call man cuz
we're going on long here and I actually
I got a practice tonight I'm actually
gonna have to run I'm sorry I'm sorry
man I'm actually after a run I think
Chris you in here is there one we want
to finish out on but brother I'm sorry
okay
okay yeah but that was interesting man I
appreciate you guys calls we had some
other you know other things we wanted to
talk about and stuff we didn't get to
him
we might do a Thursday episode this week
you know if you and I guess if you have
some suggestions for mr. Ochoa was that
his name Chris okay damn Chris you're
Latino you don't even know - come on bro
bro I'm just messing with you man
yeah but if you have uh if you have some
suggestions for him maybe that maybe
that that's that's what we'll do if you
have some I might make a Thursday
episode this week have some other stuff
we're trying to do you know we just got
to get some other things going on in
here we trying to get the studio made so
we can have a guest in sometimes and and
then we just have the rest of our lives
to get to this week but I appreciate you
guys coming to be in here this week man
uh you know I'm constantly amazed at the
little moments that I have being here
with you guys you know and I'm amazed at
a kid you know then I don't even know
who's 20 and a half from Phoenix Arizona
can send an email in you know that makes
that you know makes me feel emotional
and brings me back to a time in my life
when you know when a man gave me advice
that I could hear and sometimes that's
the toughest thing man sometimes it's
like it's crazy you can get advice a
million times or suggestions a million
times but it's just it's that one time
when you can hear them it's that one
time when there's just a connection when
you can hear them and that's what's rare
that's what's that's one thing that I'll
miss about life when I die
you know and I'm not planning on dying
inside a minute get dark there but you
know I think about that sometimes when
you know things that I'll miss and it's
those moments when you when you can hear
somebody and when you look back in your
life you're like oh wow that man took a
moment to influence me and that doesn't
mean preaching and every kid you see and
tell them what's right and what's wrong
but but I think there's there's things
you can say sometimes that can help you
know that can help young men that need
it
so I don't know if we help work with
where I'd all be able to be helpful mr.
Ochoa but if guys want to hit the
hotline nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three you know this is
what he says he said I'm not happy with
my life situation at the moment I'm
thinking of dropping out of school
I feel like school just isn't for me I
love to learn and have discussions I
don't think of myself as an idiot I've
always gotten mediocre grades
I just feel lost I'm scared of how my
friends and peers from high school think
about me when I see them at parties and
now that I can relate to to man and
scared of what my friends would think
and you know I'm still scared about that
a lot so I wish I had some suggestion
for you in that area but I still I don't
even know how to tackle it sometimes I
it's not as bad as it was when I was
your age but man I still worry a lot
about what people think but look man I
think that I appreciate you guys being
here today
happy January 22nd if you need something
hit the hotline ninety five six six four
nine five zero three we're gonna leave
out the same way that we came in with
mr. Brad Levine aka better off barefoot
be good to yourself ma'am
[Music]
thank you to everybody that came out
there out in Jacksonville who else
max kool Kat stands a crazy lady that we
had fun got nine pitches together but
she was a while everybody do Jared came
out and I'm not trying to single people
out I'm just names that are popping into
my head a lot of neat a lot of neat
ladies and gentleman came through and I
appreciate it
oh yes who's on and my crew my girl
Loretta from over there in Tampa oh yeah
we had fun
be good yourselves man bet you deserve
it